martin biron hélène budget si luc
ferrandez bonsoir à vous trois
martin rebond se fait un bout d'un
bonbon soit marcel rudloff droit
c'est tout mélanger le premier sujet
c'est comme une soupe il ya le
ras-le-bol des camionneurs ont la vue de
certains camionneurs il ya une
pâtissière dont on a parlé la semaine
dernière qui est devenu un symbole de
ces commerçants petits commerçants qui
n'en peuvent plus et les restaurateurs à
cette pression pour des cons finis alors
condé confie d'ailleurs martin je
commence avec vous est ce que on arrive
à un nouveau moment d'un nouvelle
relation entre les citoyens et les
mesures sanitaires je pense que oui il
ya une rencontre très importante qui va
débuter dans une demi heure de la
cellule de crise est à dire les experts
de la santé publique et le politique
dont le premier ministre et l'on va
prendre des décisions sur la fin on va
regarder les chiffres on s'attend à ce
que ce soit une assez longue rencontre
il y en a qui milite pour des scénarios
donc pour d'autres scénarios mais je
vais vous dire ce que j'entends
rapidement ça reste à confirmer la
convocation n'est pas sortis mais
j'entends qu'il pourrait y avoir un
point de presse demain du premier
ministre et ce qui est dans l'air c'est
la levée de certaines consignes
notamment l'ouverture des restaurants le
31 janvier je connais pas les modalités
les bulles familiale ou si on ouvriront
donner un peu plus d'air dans les
maisons je vous rappelle qu'avant noël
on avait droit à 10 personnes dans les
maisons et les supports j'entends rien
concernant la culture les salles de
spectacles de cinéma les jeans les bars
alors tout ça et puis je vous le
confirme pas mais c'est dans l'air au
moment où on se parle et comment ça ne
pourrait pas dans l'air alors que
l'ontario
l'udc a ouvert la machine nostra peu sur
la question
oui et je pense que les québécois sont
de plus en plus conscients que dans la
première phase aller première vague les
québécois se sont fait vacciner pour se
protéger dans la vague actuelle les
québécois ont la conviction qui se font
vacciner pour protéger le système de
santé et sané différence est difficile
de les mobiliser
la situation est différente au québec de
l'ontario légèrement différent mais on
est encore dans un système où il ya peu
de l'ipo disponibilité trois personnes
fréquentent if3 personnes hospitalisées
à sion convaincre les québécois que
c'est pour cette raison là qu'il faut se
battre signer c'est très difficile et je
pense que le gouvernement va proposer la
population c'est un contrat social ont
ré ouvre l'économie mais faites vous
vacciner bon et je le disais c'est
certain qu'à bien n'être pas tous mais
on voit une colère qui va pas assez de
colombie britannique jusqu'à ottawa
bond jusqu'à quel point ces
représentative mais toujours est il que
c'est là alors ils ont le sens aussi
monsieur tous des gens viendront pas en
arrière évidemment en pole pour les
vaccins mais quand même c'est partout la
wii et vous avez posé souvent la
question à vous êtes vous intervenant
plus tôt une émission serait fait que
bon bain même si monsieur trudeau
reculait ça changerait rien parce que
les états unis s impose une vaccination
obligatoire pour les camionneurs eux
aussi et vous avez raison mais en fait
les camionneurs aussi craignent la
prochaine étape et c'est à dire que
ottawa veut aussi instaurer une
obligation vaccinale pour les
camionneurs qui font du transport
interprovincial dont tous ceux qui se
promènent de l'ontario vers le québec et
chuck et heroes et c'est ça qui fait
beaucoup peur j'ai été étonné moi de
voir toutes ces associations de
camionnage se dissocier de la
manifestation est encore parce que
lorsqu on leur parlait il ya deux ou
trois semaines ou encore même il ya
quelques jours ils sont totalement
catastrophé par ses obligations
vaccinales il demande et ces
associations demandent elles aussi le
recul d'ottawa mais on n'a pas encore
une fois de s'associer à ces gens qui
sont plus visibles plus peut-être
extrême dans leur eau leur opposition
aux mesures maximales et encore une fois
on assiste à cette même
polarisation c'est à dire que ou bien on
est entièrement pour les mesures
gouvernementales ou alors on est une
frange extrémiste mais on dirait que
personne un peu entre les deux os et se
met en tête sur le billot également ce
qu'à dieu tout à l'heure que
l'association du camionnage québec était
où on voyait qu'il sait que la situation
était difficile
catastrophique dans certains endroits
mais ne voulait pas monter la pression
peut-être parce qu'il négocie puis qui
veulent convaincre les provinces le
canada donne pas plus qu'ils passent pas
au canada non oui c'est sûr qu'il ya un
peu de ça mais c'est ça aussi que quand
on interroge céquami en art l'appui
qu'on tombe sur les 2 3 qui nous disent
je veux pas me faire injecter un produit
dont je ne connais pas le contenu le
tout d'un coup on a peur d'être
contaminé par ce discours là n'empêche
que il ya un argumentaire très valable à
faire valoir du fait que bon les
vacances les camionneurs sont des
travailleurs essentiellement solitaire
qui vivent dans leurs cabines dont douze
heures par jour là le bienfaits
sanitaires de cette obligation vaccinale
n'a pas été démontrée et quand monsieur
trudeau dit la meilleure façon de ne pas
nuire aux chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est de se faire vacciner c'est pas
totalement vrai parce qu'on sait très
bien que même vacciné on peut tomber
malade et c'est parce que les gens sont
même si on voit pas l'hôpital aux autos
c'est une terreur on reste à la maison
quelques jours et ce sont ces maladies
aussi qui causent les perturbations sur
la chaîne d'approvisionnement sur les
camionneurs luc
auger reprendre la nature même du canada
d'accepter salutaire et ses deux soeurs
encore là il faut trouver le sens de
l'opération qui mobilise et motiver les
camionneurs à comprendre parce que
effectivement il ya plusieurs éléments
qui leur donne à croire que ce soit ça
dort il ne devrait pas être les
premières personnes à faire l'objet
d'une interdiction par ailleurs on sait
qu'ils ont été les rona 1re et de la 2e
vainqueurs s'appellent
des premières vagues c'était des héros
et il faut les traiter comme ça il faut
pas tout à coup en faire des dégâts
et martin cette obligation dans les
grandes surfaces là elle arrive
aujourd'hui si on annonce vous me dites
peut-être demain des assouplissements ce
que ça va pas être un peu
comment dire un double discours là c'est
que c'est une mesure qui est perçu par
certains comme et à exagérer
comment on va concilier tout ça c'est un
équilibre qui est très fragile ce plus
touchés même les camionneurs sa nuque il
est très fragile parce que les gens en
ont soupé des non vaccinés qui les
empêchent finalement de faire des choses
mais en même temps si on veut mettre les
non vaccinés au pas et les pénalisés
parce qu'ils veulent pas se protéger et
protéger la collectivité mais on impose
des obligations à des gens qui sont
vaccinées ce à dire à des propriétaires
d'entreprises des des dirigeants de
commerce on les oblige à avoir du
personnel pour surveiller les
non-vaccinés puis bon on verra surtout
les quincailliers les entreprises qui
d'entrepreneurs lucky man 2 du matériel
de construction c'était extrêmement
compliqué mais on va voir aussi dans des
grandes surfaces si effectivement il ya
plusieurs non vaccinés le qui décode
avec tous les moyens le ca dire ça prend
quelqu'un pour tester les participants
avec snow ça prend de la sécurité ça
devient extrêmement compliqué c'est des
frais supportés et c'est difficile on
passe pas qui va aller à la pharmacie
chez quand je roule doit être escorté
par un employé c'est un un bon vin on va
l'information vient
docteur boileau je reviens avec cela
fait trois fois que j'en parle depuis
début de l'émission toto boileau audi
à ces questions le oui c'est précisément
parce qu'on veut les laisser à la maison
qui sortent pas si ils sortent tous en
même temps les non vaccinés il reste
d'avoir trop d'infection en même temps
pour le système hospitalier sans qu'on
s'en cache pas le spa pour les emmerder
pour les cloîtrer presque le plat
mais absolument mais à ce moment alors
pourquoi pas l'obligation vaccinale
parce que à partir du moment où on est
rendu à ce niveau-là de cumul de mesures
pour les cloîtres et les écuries entre
guillemets même si la cabane boileau
s'en cache pas ce sens car il ya eu des
déclarations qui n'ont procédé qui ont
dit on vise à leur rendre la vie
difficile non mais est ce que est ce que
les se cumulent là commence pas à être
un peu plus doux repas au moins aussi
lourd qu'une obligation vaccinale est la
conclusion là dessus oui ben moi j'y
crois pas trop je pense sincèrement que
c'est pour précisément emmerder les
non-vaccinés parce qu'encore le là la
preuve sanitaire de l'utilité de cette
mesure dans les grandes surfaces ça
n'est pas vraiment fait dans les
restaurants où on enlève notre mars
c'est une évidence que d'être vaccinés
ces cétacés utile mais dans un canadien
de tailleur ouzou côtoyé à peu près
personne vous prenez votre produit que
vous en allez personnes nous ont montré
que c'était une source importante d'être
l'occasion bon très bien madame anglade
on va basculer
martin sur le terrain politique
elle d'abord elle a décidé de ne plus
participer aux rencontres avec le
premier ministre et les chefs de
pollution le vendredi rencontres
virtuelles et on va l'écouter où elle
explique pourquoi puis on revient sur
son aile asie l'escouade elle propose
une escouade coved 19 qui décideraient
doux et man ray des décisions de santé
publique
je vais vous demander ce que vous en
comprenait mais d'abord madame anglais
j'ai tâché d'amener des des
recommandations puis de dire qu'on
devait le faire dans le cadre de
l'assemblée nationale de manière
publique on a refusé ça ils ont refusé
qui est la présence des médias ils ont
refusé qu est la présence de la santé
publique je suis quand même prêtés au
jeu pour constater que finalement ça
marche pas puis je pense qu'on est rendu
à une étape où les gens sont tellement
fatigués et aimante années honnêtement
tout le monde est à cran fait quand
quelque chose marche pas faut qu on se
le dise l'appui qu'on se donne les
moyens de réussir là faut qu'on se dise
les choses franchement ça marche pas ça
marche pas trouvons-nous doute
mécanismes qui vont faire en sorte que
la proche va marcher cette fois-ci
bon prenons le premier élément dont j'ai
parlé son refus de participer aux
rencontres martin rapidement des savons
tous ensemble en fait madame anglade
veut changer de stratégie le sondage
léger de la semaine dernière là où elle
plafonne à 20 % c'est reçu comme un coup
de massue des dents dans les dans les
rangs libéraux ça faisait que son
congrès n'ont rien fait ça pourrait
bouger l'aiguillé faut voir les choses
au sein de son caucus même et même dans
les rangs libéraux de ce qu'on appelle
l'establishment de se dire les livres
les vieux libéro qui milite encore on
trouve que madame anglade et les passes
et mordante elle est passée fonceuse et
pas assez agressive elle devrait prendre
la balle au bond un peu plus souvent
hélas avec ces résultats là on est rendu
à cet endroit là à lui choisi de ne pas
participer de faire une manche est
finalement en claquant la porte des
rencontres qui ont lieu une fois par
semaine jusqu'à ce que la situation
commence avec les chefs de position et
le premier ministre il en restait tendue
vendredi vendredi prochain la prochaine
après c'est terminé et elle se retrouve
dans une situation de chaise vide c'est
cette décision à elle c'est une
stratégie un peu douteuse et les gens
autour d'elle commencent à se demander
pourquoi il a fait ça parce qu'elle va
le recevoir au visage celle de recul ap
ap le premier ministre ils remettent sur
le nie cependant bon il lui que
l'escouade d'abord là dessus puis il
faut former une escouade commun 19 on
s'en revient plus à cette intention des
gens ont de dépolitiser totalement la
prise de décision est ce possible
moi je pense que oui et je pense que
c'est la santé publique qui devrait
informer les élus à la ce soit
l'assemblée nationale soit dans les
mécaniques quand la botte ça va trop
vite dans des mécanismes comme des
rencontres haddock ou des rencontres
hebdomadaires
je trouve que la raison puis je pense
que la fin bon je pense que ça a roulé
tout l'aspect deux semaines ça roulait
depuis qu'elle a fait son annonce tous
les micros du québec bus on passe en
dessous dîner pour savoir pourquoi il
avait fait ça elle a pu s'expliquer être
qu'elle l'a bien expliqué ce qu'elle
était assez mordant que je sais pas mais
au moins réussi son coup et c'est vrai
que dans ces rencontres là on l'est
l'opposition fait souvent office de
plantes vertes ce à dire que tout est
décidé et puis après si on leur donne la
parole de minutes pour commenter sur la
décision vous
vous vous dites
mais oui je comprends pourquoi il essaie
de ne plus y participer on constaté
c'est pas juste au québec 7 le pays une
insatisfaction grandissante de
l'électorat envers les dirigeants parce
qu'on est année essentiellement de la
pandémie et donc elle ne veut plus avoir
l'air d'être embrigadé par le
gouvernement d'être côte à côte avec eux
pour endosser ces mesures donc c'est une
façon de politiquement prend acte de la
colère en se dissociant des décideurs
mais ceci dit ça cette kovy 19 qu'elle
propose c'est seulement une stratégie
politique consiste à tester un peu le
vent et de de dire la même chose que ce
qu'on entend dans la population des
d'odeurs de véhicules et de relayer les
critiques mais ne pas vraiment proposer
d'alternative à dimanche il faut avoir
des seuils à partir desquels on des
confinerait quel seuil il vraiment des
choses qu'on des conf confine jamais
lesquels c'est une façon essentiellement
de récupérer la colère citoyenne mais
sans nécessairement
proposer des alternatives très très
concrètement bartrès importants comme
point parce qu il ya beaucoup de gens
puis monsieur legault le répétait
souvent et dont jack disons peut pas
dépolitiser la prise de décision finale
revient au politique parce que oui
pavant des seuils mais pour avoir
d'autres facteurs la santé mentale des
enfants le fait que bon les sports par
exemple deux groupes j'espère que ce
sera annoncé demain mais peut-être qu'il
ya des pour et des contres et ce même
seuil on peut se dire oui très bien j'ai
entendu vos arguments mais je pense que
plus de pour que de compte mais c'est
mena l'argumentaire de madame anglade et
sa proposition elle est intéressante
parce que dans le fond ce qu'elle
souhaitait et le dit jeudi dans les
rencontres qu'elle a eue être le premier
ministre et les partis d'opposition que
des représentants des partis
d'opposition devraient être membre de la
cellule de crise il ils disent qu'ils
ont peu d'informations qu'ils ont et qui
manque de transparence et c'est vrai que
ces réunions là ne sont pas très
instructive pour 820 différents faits
accomplis mais
on est en la perception et c'est un peu
ça qu'elle veut madame anglade
est proposée faire partie de la solution
mais en sueur ans s'excluent 1 2 7 6
rencontres en et leur donner les faits
ce que laissait bon ben moi je vais
proposer des choses mais je suis pas
prête à collaborer et c'est ça la
difficulté dans laquelle se retrouve
maintenant bon très bien on va voir la
suite des choses mais elle
l'ema qui revient partout c'est que les
40 s'est elle a donc ce qui rend la
prise de décision plus compliquée encore
qu'au début sur l'évidence il reste 2 30
lui qu est ce qui peut avoir on va par
l'eau 18 ans tout à l'heure plus
longuement mais est ce que peut avoir
des fausses bonnes idées c'est à dire
mike ward qui dit moi je vais aller
distribuer joffre à la ville des micros
tendus je vous les donne la ville en
veut pas et l'homme madame plantes toute
la fin de semaine dû expliquer pourquoi
mais est-ce que c'était si une bonne
d'exact de mettre des temps passés voulu
vous moi je pense que c'est une mauvaise
idée faux faux rapports prenons comme
exemple l'installation de toilettes
publiques dainville ma vie à partir de
2007 un projet pilote très rapidement il
a été convenu que c'est les toilettes
publiques ne pouvait pas fonctionner si
y'avait pas une personne qui s'en
occupait une personne qui était au tour
le l'éventail de problèmes qui pouvaient
se produire se sont tous produits
c'était considéré c'était utilisés comme
des lieux de pour s'injecter il y avait
de la prostitution il y avait du bruit
de la délinquance mais lumière était
toujours qu'à s'équiper d'une maîtrise
en vous dites dans les faits mais ce que
je voulais mais dans les faits c'est
plutôt
martine un petit mot là dessus et
ncc difficile de coiffer luc sur le
terrain de montréal mais quand même j'ai
fait quand j'ai regardé un peu mes notes
je regardais qu'est ce qui s'était passé
en janvier 2021 et vous rappelez
certainement de raphaël andré qui est
décédé dans une toilette chimique la
nuit par son refuge était fermé et je
trouvais qu'il y avait un décalage entre
le terrain et ce que disait valéry
plantes c'est à dire que disent nos
personnels mais il manque de place oui
conclusion il ya toujours le risque
aussi quand on est on offre des
installations comme celle de pérenniser
dé certains des villages de d'itinérance
on a mis ce problème est ici à gatineau
et il ya peut-être d'autres solutions
parce qu'on sait qu'il est inhérent
s'est vu plus profond c'est pas juste
une question de trouver un toit pour la
nuit ça se manifeste plus en période de
grand froid ici en outaouais par exemple
on a simplement réquisitionner des
motels dans la région pour loger de
manière ponctuelle pendant les grands
froids ces gens le très bien merci à
vous trois et jean va parler au
téléjournal de 18h donc avec l'udc avec
un igp on aura un reportage complet
dessus ce que des fois ça pète séduisant
mais dans les détails c'est plus
compliqué
merci au revoir bonne soirée au revoir
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit